[موسيقى]
لا يوجد امه من الامم اهتمت بتفاصيل
ودقائق السماء من نجم وسدم ورعد وبرق كحال
الامه العربيه ليش لانهم اهل تنقل وترحل
في صحراء متراميه الاطراف ومتشابهه
المعالم فهم يعتمدون على النجوم في تنقلهم
وترحلهم وفصولهم ومواسمهم فعلاقتهم
بالسماء علاقه حياتيه وجوديه تطورت الى
علاقه وجدانيه اقلب طرفي في السماء لعله
يوافق طرفي طرفها
حين تنظروا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
والعرب قسموا المطر الى الرذاذ قطرات
المطره خفيفه والعامه يسمونه بالذرذر الرش
هو المطر الخفيف التيم هو المطر الدائم
الهتان هو المطر المتتابع الوابل هو
المطره غزير ذات الحبه الكبيره الحياه هو
الذي يحيي الارض الغيث هو الذي ياتينا بعد
انقطاع طويل الغدق المطر الغزير وان لو
استقاموا على الطريقه لاسقيناهم ماء غدقه
[موسيقى]